[Música]
Cómo avanzamos en nuestros titulares
despegó con éxito desde cabo Cañaveral
en el estado de la Florida en Estados
Unidos el cohete sls de la NASA a bordo
la cápsula no tripulada de la
tripulación orión aparte de la misión
Artemisa 1 que representa un primer
esfuerzo de una misión más amplia que
buscará llevar de nuevo el hombre a la
luna y establecer una presencia
sostenible en el satélite terrestre
previamente de mi compañera Ángela Gómez
habló con Rey Díaz él es supervisores de
tecnología aeroespacial de Centro
espacial Kennedy en Florida de la NASA
quienes amplió los objetivos de la
misión carta de mis primos la entrevista
este mes se cumplen 50 años desde que la
NASA dio luz verde para la que sería
considerada una de las mayores travesías
de la humanidad la llegada a la luna la
nave arte de mí se repite esta hazaña y
por eso vamos a conocer eso sobre las
minucias y para ello me acompaña Rey
Díaz él es supervisor de tecnología
aeroespaciales del centro espacial
Kennedy en Florida de la NASA bienvenido
rey y por qué hizo falta medio siglo
para decidir volver a la luna
Este es el momento preciso de regresar
de vuelta a la luna luego de haber hecho
exploración en otras áreas del espacio
en particular cercano a la tierra con
nuestra estación espacial estamos
preparados para rezarles vuelta a
nuestra exploración a nuestro planeta a
nuestro cuerpo Celeste más cercano que
nuestra luna bueno y cuáles son las
características especiales de la misión
artemis
en esta misión vamos no solamente a
probar este cohete el más poderoso que
hemos desarrollado a través de la
historia sino también la cápsula Ryan
que va a permitir llevar hasta cuatro
astronautas a bordo y yo luego de esta
misión de prueba vamos a llevar a la
superficie de la luna la primera mujer y
el primer hombre de color en la
superficie de la luna en la tercera
misión de esta serie bien y por qué es
importante hacer esas medidas que se
podrían llamar de inclusión de incluir
una mujer o una afrodescendiente en esta
misión de nuevo Le repito después de ya
cinco décadas de no haber regresado a la
luna lo cual es cuando menos es
llamativo que se haya tardado tanto
tiempo la Nasa en poder regresar
ha tomado un tiempo en regresar a los
seres humanos de vuelta a nuestro a
nuestra luna sin embargo durante estos
años hemos tenido la oportunidad de
continuar la exploración y conocimiento
del planeta de nuestros cuerpos celestes
que por la razón de que hemos enviado
misiones robóticas en algunas de ellas
para lograr entonces entender qué serían
los lugares propicios para hacer estas
misiones con seres humanos esta misión
de prueba es muy importante porque no
solamente desarrolla la capacidad de
llevarnos hasta la luna pero
eventualmente llevarnos a otros destinos
Como por ejemplo Marte Bueno sobre eso
le quería preguntar por qué es de tanto
interés para la agencia espacial una
nueva visita a la luna Qué tiene de
importante este astro
si hemos hecho investigación y
exploración muy cercana a la tierra con
los seres humanos de hecho la estación
espacial internacional que se encuentra
flotando en estos momentos con una
tripulación a bordo ha estado en
continuo funcionamiento por 22 años
estamos listos para ir un poquito más
allá de nuestro planeta ir a cercanos
entonces a otros destinos la luna es muy
importante para nosotros en la luna se
va a poder describir y desarrollar
instrumentos capacidades que nos van a
ser utilizadas nuevamente en otros
puntos en particular Marte para
establecer estos recursos y estas
capacidades vamos a entender Cómo se
vive fuera de la tierra en un sitio
distante bueno precisamente una de las
ideas de la misión Artemisa es que se
pueden en algún momento establecer una
presencia a largo plazo que se instalen
en satélite como usted Nos estaba
empezando a describir Cómo se logrará
eso qué tiempo tomará que se pueda
establecer esa misión permanente Sí esta
esta serie de misiones van a desarrollar
No solamente la oportunidad de llevar
seres humanos sino de establecer puntos
donde se pueda visitar y vivir por
tiempos extendidos estos también te va a
ser con puntos de transferencias que se
encuentran localizados cerca de la luna
y con estos puntos de transferencia
vamos a ver no solamente la capacidad de
poder regresar a la superficie de la
luna sino transportar estos seres
humanos a otros puntos más distantes por
ejemplo martes en el caso de los
recursos que tenemos en la luna es muy
importante desarrollarlos Ya que no
tenemos entonces que llevarlo desde la
Tierra desde este punto desde la luna
podemos colocar Entonces estos recursos
más allá de nuestra luna y haces otro
punto destinos que vamos a tener en el
futuro bueno y cuáles son las ambiciones
respecto de martes y la Luna sería un
punto intermedio para avanzar mucho más
en la exploración de nuestro sistema
solar En cuáles son los intereses que
hay en este momento científicamente
hablando para arribar hasta Marte bueno
la luna obviamente es una importantísimo
para nuestro planeta primero que nada
queremos entender cómo está este cuerpo
es desarrolló a través de los tiempos
queremos utilizar los recursos que
podamos encontrar en la superficie y
dentro la superficie y queremos utilizar
estas esta experiencia que vamos a tener
viviendo en la luna para entonces
transportar esa experiencia a otros
puntos ejemplo en la capa todavía orión
por ejemplo tenemos la capacidad de
estar en el espacio mucho más tiempo que
ninguna otra nave espacial O sea que
vamos a establecer presencia humana en
otros puntos distantes y Cuáles serían
esos puntos distantes porque la misión
digamos o a largo plazo la proyección es
que incluso se vayan Más allá de marte
Sí por ejemplo estás en espacial la
investigación y la viajes Son de días en
el caso de perdón horas en el caso de la
exploración a la luna se mide en días en
el caso de la exploración a Marte se
mide en meses o sea que estamos hablando
de que cada paso incremental nos da la
capacidad de hacer misiones más
extendidas y de mucho mayor extensión y
complejidad bueno Y tenemos entendido
que tras Este primer lanzamiento de las
futuras emisiones del programa artemis
podrían hacerse cada vez más complejas
porque esto
si la idea es que todo lo que hemos
aprendido a través de los tiempos no
solamente con misiones robóticas sino
también con los seres humanos con las
gramos con los seres humanos en la
superficie de la luna Esto será
transportado será llevado a esos puntos
distantes por ejemplo una una cápsula de
transferencia un punto de transferencia
es muy importante para nosotros ya
tenemos la capacidad de hacerlo cerca de
la tierra con la estación espacial
internacional queremos hacerlo en otros
puntos donde podamos colocar esto y
utilizar Entonces esto como punto de
reabastecimiento o acoplamiento para los
otros admisiones
Y qué es lo que esperan encontrar
inicialmente Cuáles son las
características de esta superficie lunar
con las que se encontrarían más adelante
en otras misiones si lo que están
esperando es establecer poblaciones
bueno que inicialmente estamos buscando
Establecer un punto de exploración en el
área de Polo Sur si esto ocurre de esta
manera vamos a tener la oportunidad de
utilizar los recursos que se encuentran
en esa área entre ellas los recursos que
se encuentran en el terreno la
posibilidad de extraer agua que se
encuentra en manera sólida Y entonces
con esto establecer la oportunidad de
utilizar estos recursos para ya hacer
esto que sea estructuras o material que
le va a permitir proporción desde la
luna a esos puntos distantes pues
muchísimas gracias Rey Díaz supervisor
de tecnología aeroespaciales del centro
espacial Kennedy en Florida y desde la
NASA hablando para Francia 24 gracias a
ustedes Muchas gracias Ángela